hello everyone and welcome to a prequel
of a video I made over some four years
ago what I mean by this is that this is
a game from the singfield cup and it's
ding Len versus Magnus Carlson now a lot
of you have been seeing in the previous
um videos that I made about ding Len
that uh if Magnus uh was still
interested in playing classical and if
he was to face ding that the result
would be well Magnus coming up on top
either by just drawing the classical and
then defeating the in the Rapids or the
blitz or uh it wouldn't even be
competitive but what I uh what I would
like to show you is something that tus
senson posted on Twitter this is
magnus's uh rating performance over the
years ever since he became a world
champion now as you can see he became a
world champion in
2010 and uh sorry in 2013 this is well
over that this is since he was the
highest rated player in the world since
2010 and uh every year his rating
performance is over 2800 so so 289 2840
2875 2875 28 49 28 29 2834 2807 at 2835
and then in 2019 which is magnus's
absolute best year his rating
performance is
2889 so almost 2900 In classical chess
which is uh I mean which is mindboggling
then in 2020 20185 then 28 29 28 33 uh
and now in
2023 27 87 so it's the first time since
2010 since Magnus became world champion
that his rating performance in classical
chess is below 2800 he lost six games in
total which for him is quite a lot uh
but okay in his uh in his defense he did
face a whole lot of lower rated players
he played um 2500 players he played 2600
players which a lot of the top players
don't do and they will not um lose as
much on rating because if he loses a
game to a 2500 you know that he's it's
very hard to be uh have a rating
performance of 2800 at the end of the
year and okay the year still isn't over
but um it is uh probably considered that
Magnus will not be playing any more
classical chess in um 2023 so while it
could change for the moment it is below
2,800 and what I wanted to show you is
the game that Magnus played against ding
where uh probably both Magnus and ding
were at their strongest they played the
you know they played engine chess they
were like two engines uh and that is
2019 singfield cup where uh in the
classical section of the singfield cup
they they drew their game then they went
into the tie breaks where the two rapid
games ended in a draw and then they went
into a series of Blitz playoffs which
means that they will play two Blitz
Games if it's a draw two more Blitz
Games it's a draw then two more Blitz
Games until they reach armagon but
everything was concluded in the first
set of the two Blitz Games and I've
shown you the second game I've called it
the Immortal playoffs game for those of
you who haven't seen it or haven't been
following the channel in 2019 it's the
first link in the description below and
it's a game you should watch before
checking out this game or you can check
it out after you watch this game but
this is the first game that led to that
Immortal playoffs game so let's check it
out ding has the white pieces and he
opened with Pawn to C4 he opened with
the English opening Knight to F6 by
Magnus G3 and now Pawn to E6 uh we have
Bishop to G2 and now Pawn to D5
uh Knight to F3 and now D captures on C4
by Magnus we have Queen to A4 with check
this is all very standard stuff much
like you would see today KN bd7 Queen
captures and C4 A6 and now Queen back to
C2 of course you are expecting B5 so C5
here Knight to C3 and now Queen to C7 so
they of course have to play very quickly
as it's a Blitz game uh D4 and now C
captures on D4 Knight captures and
Bishop to C5 we have Knight to B3 and
Bishop back to D6 we have castles
castles and now Rook to D1 and Bishop to
E5 we have Bishop to E3 and Knight to D5
now offering a trade on D5 but for the
moment it's impossible as the queen on
C2 is undefended so Bishop captures on
D5 e captures on D5 and now Rook a to C1
now the Knight can move as the queen on
C2 is defended so Knight to F6 adding a
Defender here but not really as Knight
captures on D5 lands we have Knight
captures Rook captures Queen captures on
C2 Rook captures and now Bishop to F6
getting the bishop to safety so here
ding is up a pawn uh but it's very very
hard to prove that in a Blitz game so
let's see what happened here Knight to
C5 we have Rook to E8 and now Bishop to
D4 offering a trade of dark Square
Bishop so Bishop to E7 and now Rook to
E5 preventing the Bishop from moving as
The Rook here would be hanging so F6 we
have Rook to E3 and now Bishop to F5 now
the Rooks are connected and now the
bishop can move uh Rook to D2 by Ding
and now Bishop captures on C5 for a very
very obvious reason taking um the Knight
for Bishop Rook captures and8 with check
Rook captures and now Bishop captures
and C5 and what you can notice right
away is that yes Magnus is down a pawn
but he was able to trade down into an
endgame of opposite colored Bishops yes
the Rooks are still on the board but if
the Rooks come off the board then you
know that okay being up a pawn in an
opposite color Bop end game uh you you
will very likely be able to draw this so
what ding will do is of course he will
prevent Magnus from uh trading Rooks and
what Magnus will do is of course try to
trade Rooks actively unless he has a
very active Rook then of course he will
remain have it remain on the board so
Rook to C8 goes after the bishop Pawn to
B4 defending and now Pawn to A5 going
after the pawn here A3 a captures a
captures and now Rook to C7 not allowing
uh that uh that pawn to be attacked
we have F3 and now Rook to D7 offering a
rook trade and ding of course if he
wants to have winning chances he will
have to decline this so Rook day2
because if ding draws this then he goes
into the second place game where Magnus
will have the white pieces and then if
he loses that then Magnus wins the
singfield cup 2019 Pawn to H5 we have
King to F2 now bringing the king into
the game and Magnus does the same King
F7 we have Pawn to H4 Bishop to E6 and
now Rook to A8 with have Pawn to B5 and
now Pawn to E4 uh Bishop to C4 the
bishop is now nicely defended and here
Magnus just says all right uh yes you up
a pawn but here this structure will not
move anytime soon and you have four
against three on the king's side how are
you how are you going to make any
progress here so of course ding has to
try King E3 Rook D3 check King F4 and
now Rook to D7 and this is the moment
where Magnus gives Ding A Chance the way
to play this uh is to actually go Rook
to B three simply uh move the Rook from
the bishop and now Bishop to E2 will be
the threat so ding will not have time to
go after the H Pawn with something like
Rook to h8 uh which is exactly what
happened in the game Magnus played Rook
to D7 and now Rook to h8 going after the
H5 Pawn here King to G6 and now Pawn to
G4 uh H captures and G6 H captures King
to F7 and now Pawn to H5 Dean grabs more
space on the king side here controls the
G6 square and now Bishop to B three by
Magnus sort of a waiting move uh the the
way to to keep this um equal is Pawn to
G5 with check where okay you are giving
him a pass Pawn uh but if d goes forward
you can just Checkmate him with Bishop
to E6 Checkmate uh so he will have to go
backwards King to E3 and then the game
continues it's not easy to make progress
here H but Magnus instead went Bishop to
B3 like I said sort of a sort of a
waiting move here uh maybe with some
ideas of later on going after the the
pawns here but now Pawn to E5 by ding G5
was also very strong he played Pawn to
E5 F captures on E5 and now King
captures on E5 with Rook to D5 check
King to F4 and now Rook to D1 uh trying
to annoy the white king with checks so
Rook to f8 with check King to E6 and
Rook to E8 with check now King F7 Rook
f8 check King E6 and now King to G5 D
has to go forward if he wants to avoid
repetition Bishop to C2 H and now we
have Rook to E8 with check King back to
F7 Rook E7 check King G8 Rook to B7 and
Rook to D5 now with check King to H4 and
now Bishop back to D3 guarding the B5
pawn and now Pawn to G5 this is the best
way to continue Rook to d8 uh and now
Pawn to G6 and now you also have some
issues of F7 and H7 being defended and
um if the the black R Rook moves from
the back rank then Rook to B8 will be
Checkmate or Rook anywhere along the
back rank so Bishop to C4 and now King
to G5 Rook to D5 with check King to F4
Rook back to d8 and now Bishop to D6
possible uh because like we said if the
Rook moves Rook to B8 will be Checkmate
once you H give up The Rook so instead
after Bishop to D6 Bishop to E2 by
Magnus and now sorry Bishop to E2 by
Magnus going after the H5 pawn and now
uh well it might seem like ding should
defend the pawn he actually doesn't he
goes Bishop to E5 and attacks the G7
Pawn so he gives up the h 5 Pawn for the
G7 Pawn Magnus captures it and now King
to G5 we have Bishop to E2 and now Rook
captures on G7 with check King to f8 and
now Rook to sorry Rook to F7 with check
King to uh of course you go here you
don't go under the mask of the bishop
King F6 Bishop to C4 and now Rook to H7
uh and here both of them were below 10
seconds on the clock they were playing
an increment the cleanest way to win
this is Rook to E7 check but still it's
not very easy I'm going to going to show
it because it's a lot of fun King f8 now
you play Bishop C7 you go after the rook
and once The Rook moves you go for
Bishop to D6 now you uh go for this and
after the king moves you will play a
check and after the king moves now
Bishop to E5 and this is now um
uh you know impossible to solve for
black Rook E8 you will play Bishop to D4
and if you persist to go after the
bishop now Rook D7 threatening mate in
one so Rook to E8 and now Rook to H with
check uh King to G8 and now Rook to G7
with check King f8 and Bishop to C5 and
now black has to part with the rook and
very soon uh Checkmate will follow so uh
Rook to H7 was played instead also
winning but it will take um more
grinding we have Rook to D1 by Magnus
now he wants to give all those uh
necessary checks behind the black king
Rook D7 check King to d8 and now Rook to
A7 uh we have Rook to F1 check King G7
King to E E8 and now Bishop to F6 with
have Rook D1 again uh just waiting for
for ding to try and move the king to
make progress which he does but now Rook
to H1 with check King G7 and Rook D1
Magnus says all right you figure out a
way out of this I'm happy with a draw
here and then I'm going to take my uh
Chances with the white pieces so Rook B7
uh Rook to E2 Rook A7 Rook D1 Rook to C7
and Rook back to E2 so again very
drawish but now Rook to A7 uh Rook to C8
check was was very very strong but okay
uh players playing on increment here
Rook to A3 Rook to E2 and now Rook to A8
with check King D7 King to f8 now again
ready to push that pawn but Rook to F2
threatening to win the bishop so King G7
and King to G2 ding still unable to
figure out a way out of this Rook to d8
check was played King to E6 Rook to E8
with check King to D7 and Rook to E5 and
here believe it or not the position is
uh now a dead draw because ding missed
something when he played this Rook to E5
move uh do you see it even without
pausing the video I'm sure you guys can
what what did ding miss
here uh well he missed Bishop to D3 uh
and Magnus also missed it because they
were playing quite quickly but yeah
Bishop to D3 and now uh there there's no
way to actually win this game even if
even if you block with the Rook you can
simply capture and after captures just
go King E6 and the problem is yes you
will be able to advance the pawn finally
to G7 but it will not do any good after
G7 for example King F7 and uh the king
cannot help out with the advancement of
the pawn and the bishop also cannot help
as the pawn shoot Queen on a light
Square you have a dark Square Bishop so
you're not going to be able to do
anything here so instead after Rook e
five Magnus play King to D6 and now the
position is once again objectively
winning for ding uh but you know with a
little time on the clock that's not easy
to achieve Rook E3 King D7 Rook to E 7
with check King to D6 and Rook to E3
King D7 King to H6 and now Rook to H2
with check we have King to G7 Rook to G2
and Bishop to D4 we have Rook to G4
Bishop to C5 and now Rook to G2 and he
was in this position on move 87 that
Magnus Carlson lost on time yeah that's
what happened uh and ding got a win here
and then uh in the second game Magnus
had to win in order to to tie the tie
breaks to to push it into the second
half of the tie breaks to go for another
set of Blitz Games H but that is where
ding absolutely shined with the black
pieces he sacrificed his Queen for a
spectacular double bishop checkmate uh
that's why I called it the immortal
playoffs game and if you haven't seen it
still first link in the description
below it's probably the greatest thing
you will see today maybe even you know
the whole week or or even a month I
don't know how your month was but it
could very well be the greatest thing
you will see for the entire month uh and
uh yeah here okay Magnus lost on time
and even though the possession is
objectively winning it's not easy to win
this now I mean really sock this in here
is where I want you to pause the video
as I haven't covered this four years ago
when the game actually happened because
immediately game two was played and I
was watching it live I was having a lot
of fun and then when I saw game two that
Immortal playoffs game no one really
cared about this game anymore uh but
it's really tricky how to win this so
yeah feel free to pause the video and
try to figure out a a winning plan here
for uh for ding while I give you a
couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being a true
student of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show well
while many moves are possible here you
go Rook E4 Rook E5 uh the strongest way
to play this is Rook to E7 with check
and once the king moves doesn't really
matter where you're going to play Rook
to A7 now what's the idea behind Rook to
A7 uh it's a very tricky maneuver uh
where the bishop and Rook kind of hold
the black king here the the black king
only has these two squares and you don't
really care what the black king does
point is that now you will be able to
move your king as if Rook captures on G6
then Rook to A6 check will win the Rook
so that's the free maneuver and now
after let's say Rook to G3 you will play
King to f8 and of course uh now if
captures you're just going to play Rook
to A6 check and win The Rook but if
let's say Bishop to A6 so now if Rook to
A6 check you will have the bishop
blocking so you don't have to worry
about it Rook captures and G6 is
happening now you play Rook to A6 check
uh and after King to D5 you go King to
G7 you defend your Pawn one more time
and now you uh play whatever black plays
let's say Rook to F3 you will play Rook
to B6 you go after the pawn and there is
no way to defend the pawn so you were
using uh everything on the board the the
pass Pawn the the weird positioning of
the king and the Rook to actually win
the B5 pawn and uh then your B4 Pawn
will be able to advance and win the game
problem is that uh you can't defend if
Bishop to D7 Rook to D6 check just uh
wins the bishop if you try anything else
let's say Rook to G3 you might be
interested in let's say Bishop captures
on B5 then you're going to go here and
win this Pawn here King to F6 is
actually very strong because after Rook
to F3 check you will go King to E7 and
the bishop is still hanging so once the
bishop moves now you play G7 and now
after Rook to G3 King F7 and Rook to F3
check you will block with Rook to F6 and
now after Bishop to E six check you will
move the king and now after Rook to G3
again stopping queening you will play
King to f8 and now finally after a rook
move or something you will play Rook
captures on E6 with check Rook captures
on E6 and after you capture G8 Queen
Rook captures King captures and now you
will simply win this the king will go
over to the queen side pick up the B5
pawn and then Advance this Pawn to
Victory so that's uh that's how you do
it and yeah after Rook to B6 there's
really not not much uh else you you
either defend and lose the bishop or you
try to defend it this way and you're
going to lose it that way so uh yeah it
was possible to win this but you've seen
how long it took ding was winning for
like 40 Mo and he couldn't do it Magnus
was just defending so well and with a
little time on the clock it's just not
easy to do it uh but it's something that
I wanted to show you as there's a lot of
discussion like uh you know if Magnus
was really interested in playing ding
everyone's uh like yeah but if if Magnus
like has a good day and if he's playing
his best then um of course no one has a
chance but ding actually played Magnus
at his best uh objectively uh 2019 with
Magnus is best if you're considering
rating performance 2889 that's almost
2900 I mean that's uh and ding dominated
him he he he drew the classical game he
drew the two rapid games and then he won
the two Blitz Games uh which I really
wanted to show you but I've already
shown you the The Immortal playoffs game
first link in the description below like
maybe even the best thing you will see
this year uh do check it out quite
amazing and if you guys want I don't
know since it's an old video it's only
made at 30 frames per second if you guys
have you know are struggling watching
that I could remake it I don't mind uh
so you know I write um you know remake
or or you know with like a new version
or or even just like this video I never
I never care about likes or anything and
I I think they're pretty much
meaningless you know uh for your videos
but uh we could use them as a sort of a
voting mechan mechanism if if we really
need it at times so yeah if you really
want me to do it you can even like this
video as all of my pre all of my videos
get the same amount of likees so if I
see like sort of a spike then I'll know
you guys are interested in that so yeah
maybe that's also something we could do
uh but yeah just something I wanted to
show you so this is a a prequel that's
been four years long overdue I hope you
enjoyed that I would like to thank David
gasparian Sashu desert send software ajs
3 TB and more ding games thank you for
tion to my channel thank you a lot I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon contining to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day